Oren you just heard the president saying
that Secretary Austin,
General Austin,
former general, now
the secretary of defense
recommended this.
But we've talked in recent weeks
about how the Pentagon
was somewhat resistance
because of the logistics involved,
because of the
the resupply and the keeping, the tanks
and the training involved,
how quickly
the American tanks get there,
and how big of a difference
does the Pentagon think they can make?
The short answer
that is not quickly at all.
These have to be procured
and then you have to train the Ukrainians
on logistics, maintenance
operations of a complex system.
And that's on top of all the new systems
you already need to train them
on the U.K.
Challenger tanks,
the German leopard tanks,
us Paladin Howitzers,
the Patriot missile system.
So it's not a rush
to get these to the front.
The other systems
and Germany's
leopard tanks are their priority.
But Biden did say
they would begin training
Ukrainian forces on the Abrams
to make sure
that when they're ready to go,
Ukrainians can use them immediately
when they arrive in country.
John on leave the Pentagon, thank you.
Let's continue the conversation
bringing two of our best.
Nick Paton Walsh joins us
live from London.
General Mark Hertling joins us as well.
Nick, I want to start with you.
You wrote a fantastic piece
about the strategic implications of this
for CNN.
It's on the Internet.
I urge everybody
to go to see an intercom and read it.
You say this, among other things,
it is a momentous decision, partly
because these are not defensive weapons.
They are intended to hit
Russia's troops
hard in a ground offensive.
They are unequivocally
about Ukraine retaking territory.
This is a new and fierce
and it portrays a NATO's unafraid
this is its help for Zelensky
that is long asked for.
But this is, as the United States
has said, a message to Vladimir Putin,
You thought we would blink.
You thought we would crumble.
Just the contrary.
Yeah.
And it is frankly hard to say
after the weeks
in which
we've seen
this diplomatic tussle
with Germany reluctant
to give authorization for leopards
to be used, manufactured in Germany,
now being portrayed as kind of the leader
of this European effort
by Joe Biden,
they're getting Lepre
thanks to Ukraine as quickly as possible.
Fundamentally, at the end,
another sign of Western unity.
Now, Joe Biden was clear there to talk
about how
this is not
an offensive capability,
suggesting essentially
that Ukraine
is always defending itself,
even when it goes on the offensive
inside its territory to kick Russia out.
A valid argument,
I think you would say,
but certainly
it shows that the West
is no longer concerned
about giving elements of its weaponry,
which it might have closely guarded,
to potentially defend itself
from an escalation by Russia.
It does appear that most of those nations
giving forward their advanced weaponry
don't think they're necessarily
going to need it to defend themselves
in an escalation of conflict
in the months or years ahead.
And it also suggests
that this consistent drip
feeding from the Kremlin,
the idea that some sort of escalation
might follow
if the West crossed some red lines
that weren't to Russia's liking,
then they're not really afraid
of that anymore,
that they've heard the nuclear rhetoric.
They've challenged it openly.
They've signaled against Russia's
sort of nuclear blackmail,
as some have referred to it.
And they might start to begin
to wonder now what else could happen.
It's important to point out, though,
that these tanks
are not suddenly going
to turn up overnight
and radically change the battlefield.
There aren't that many initially pledge
they will take months to put into
training, certainly.
And Joe Biden
there was keen to point out
that there'll be a lot
of training happening now for Ukrainians
to be able to get these complex
logistical systems up and ready.
This is a huge country
with vast amounts of terrain
to fight over and to take tanks
back,
potentially to repair
depots that need some kind of refit.
So a huge task ahead.
But it does do one important thing,
and it tells those in Moscow
planning the months ahead
that they have a very small window
until Ukraine's
weaponry gets incrementally
and enormously better in its quality.
And that is something
I'm sure that will be weighing
on the morale of those
in Russia's military.
General Hertling, come in on that point.
Your distinguished resumé
includes commander, U.S. forces, Europe.
So you understand the capabilities here.
You also understand the terrain here.
What is the military significance here
on the battlefield?
And what message is Nick just notes,
does it send to Putin?
Well, I'm impressed
by everyone's commentary on this,
because you're getting it mostly right,
John, both you and Nick and what I'd say,
tanks are
primarily used for tactical
offensive operations,
shock action, rapid maneuver,
lethal firepower.
They are both physically
and psychologically intimidating
when used.
But here's the key point
when used correctly,
and that requires the training
when we're talking about the numbers
that have been
bandied around this morning,
the president just said that
Germany is providing
two tank battalions worth of equipment
a German tank
battalion is about 44 tanks.
So maybe you're talking
80 tanks from Germany.
There are 13 other allied and partner
nations in Europe
that also use the Leos,
the Leopard, two tanks.
So you could see other ones
like Poland
and other
other countries jumping on the bandwagon.
President Biden mentioned
the US is giving 31 Abrams
that's one Ukrainian
battalion three companies of ten
plus an additional tank
for the battalion commander.
So we're talking about certainly
a lesser number
than General Zelinsky
the chief of the Ukrainian ground
forces wanted he asked for 300 tanks.
I've kind of thought
that he's the maximum
they're going to get into
Ukraine is about 100 to 150 early on
But the thing is is as Nick
just pointed out,
this is going to take a long time.
The German Leos are a short
term solution.
They can train up on them.
It's a simple diesel
engine weapon system.
There is transfer ability.
Like Sam said, it's more how I ride.
I'd counter what Sam said.
It's more than just learning
how to drive the tanks.
There's a lot of mechanics involved
and resupply
and recovery opportunities here.
The Abrams is much more complex
and that's a longer commitment
to Ukraine.
The leaders are probably going
to get there within two to three months.
The Abrams,
you know, I'd put the estimate on that
in terms of the
what I know
about maintaining and logistics
support for Abrams.
I'm going to say
that's a longer term
commitment to Ukraine's
continued military transformation.
It's going to take between six
to eight months
for those vehicles to get there.
So a reminder, reminder, as we approach
the one year anniversary
of the beginning of this war
that everybody expects it
to go well into a second year
as well as we go through this.
General Hurley,
Nick Paton Walsh, grateful
for the important insights.
And we'll continue
to stay on top of this story
as the tanks
now will be delivered to the battlefield
in Ukraine in the days, weeks and
months ahead.